um hi everyone Christians and the other
thanks there's many other things for
organizing this thing so I'm going to
talk about the who morphing encryption
is the the slide indicated but let me
just give like a very short exposition
to this morning so Danielle and you know
what they can myself was sort of trying
to figure out a way to tell you this the
story about all these all these new
developments and I'm going to start by
talking about fully homomorphic
encryption but Daniel and and really
what they're actually going to show you
is that this more polymorphic encryption
scheme which is quite wonderful by
itself can actually be seen as just one
phase of a really beautiful mathematical
structure that can be used to achieve
other exciting a cryptographic goals so
for the next 40 in some minutes you
should you can just forget about this
whole thing and just think about
homomorphic encryption and then we'll
see how it fits into this larger
framework so I meant to the most of this
audience have please sort of see you
know what this it takes to talk about
the encryption or heard about it but if
you do need the motivating example we
can think about this problem of
outsourcing computation where we have
this weak device that wants to use a
strong server in order to compute some
function and there many real-life
examples as to why we want to do it and
also some things like some you know just
for cryptographic purposes and reasons
why why this would be sought-after more
formally we have a client that has an
input and we have a server that knows
how to compute some function and we want
the client wants to is a server to
compute this this f of X so the way it's
normally done now we're just going to
send them to the server the server is
going to compute and send us the output
and this works great so long as we sort
of don't care about the server knowing
our input and you can think about some
cases
where
input the X is actually private and you
don't want the server to learn anything
about it to learn anything about X oh
that's the problem of privately
outsourcing computation and we would
like to allow the server to perform
processing on the input in a blindfolded
manner in terms of the most natural ways
to POG refers to think about sort of
sending information in a way that the
stock reveal its content is using
encryption so we would like to take our
input encrypt it and send it to the
server I know the server well just by
the security of the encryption scheme
should learn nothing about the contents
about X itself but we still want to
allow the server to compute on this
information
so obviously the server does not know X
so it cannot produce f of X itself but
hopefully it will be able to sort of
work on this encryption of X and produce
some value Y that we can decrypt locally
to get to get the value F of x that we
want so really sort of the semantics
that we're looking for is what we call a
whole morphic evaluation function and
this is a function that takes a
description of this procedure if they
want the server wants to carry out an
encryption of the input and produces an
encryption of the output so I won't want
to want to get away to go from
encryption of the input to encryption of
the output using only public information
so without the server learning anything
about the input X itself and this leads
us to the actual definition of a fully
homomorphic encryption so it's an
encryption scheme and we're thinking
about saying the public key setting so
we're going to start by a key generation
process for generating a secret key and
a public key for our scheme and the
public key can be known to anyone in
particular this server and like any
public key encryption scheme we're going
to use the public key
inputs so in this case the party that
does both the encryption and decryption
is the same person and this is actually
quite an interesting case by by itself
we can also allow like the normal public
key setting to have a third party that
does the infection so the encrypt or
decrypt it did not have to be the same
person and then the server he knows the
function that he wants to compute and he
knows the you know he has the encrypt in
English so he will be able to execute a
homomorphic evaluation procedure and
obtain this value this value Y and our
correctness requirement is that if you
know someone decrypted and improperly
and the server executed this for morphic
evaluation properly then when we decrypt
we really should get the value f of X
that we want so this is what morphing
encryption is supposed to is supposed to
provide and of course in addition to
correctness we also want our privacy the
sensitive bugger here so but the privacy
turns out to be a defined in sort of the
most obvious way this is just the same
as semantic security for any other
public a purchase scheme so we don't
need to worry too much about the
definition of security so we just want
to say that for all X and the question
of X is going to be computationally
indistinguishable from an encryption of
zero and this should of course hold true
even for a distinguished sure that knows
the public key so this is just standard
semantic security the serve gimmick of
of homework encryption is more in terms
of functionality being able to perform
these morphic evaluations so if you
think about it for a bit you can you can
see that if you know this this is all
that that we want then this is very easy
to achieve just by sort of cheating I
could just define this homomorphic a
value
as a function that sort of does nothing
it just outputs its input so I can take
my wife to just be F and the encryption
of X themselves and sort of push all the
work down to the decryption and define a
decryption process that sort of takes a
couple of function and ciphertext and
first of all the crypts the the
ciphertext and then evaluate the
function therefore sort of going back to
the solution of doing everything locally
and sort of just to prevent this
degenerate solution our going to require
a condition that's called compactness
and there are many ways to define it but
for now just think about it or not for
now for this talk just think about it as
requiring that this value Y the output
of the whole morphic evaluation should
not depend its length should not depend
on the function f so it doesn't
necessarily have to look exactly the
same as a fresh encryption of f of X but
it should not it should not grow as we
as we changed the function that we want
that we want to evaluate so this says
this is this is a morphic encryption and
when we talk about fully homomorphic
encryption what we mean by fully is that
we want this we want to want to allow
the server to evaluate any function that
it wants so we want this correct this
condition to hold for any efficiently
computable F and actually you can even
extend it to in efficiently computable
so long as the server's as long as the
server has the sufficient computational
power to execute the function and so
this seems like a pretty formidable task
to allow correctness for any possible
for any possible function but you know
we already know how to take these
functions and represent them as circuits
and then break those circuits into gates
and and getting
prism with respect to these tiny
building blocks is going to give us is
going to give us correctness for the
whole thing and we need the tasks that
are tasks when constructing a home
working three teams will be to get home
morphism for a universal set of gates so
in particular one easy to handle
Universal set of gates it's just a NAND
gate we know that any polynomial size
circuit can be made to be composed of
NAND gates at all main gates and nothing
else but another perhaps more popular
choice is to think about sort of a more
meta case and think about addition and
multiplication gates
so actually addition if we get addition
and multiplication over really any a
field or even any ring this should be
good enough because well we can think
about just having let's say we have
addition and multiplication and we can
just represent the wires of our circuits
just as the values 0 and 1 so not even
use old values that this that this field
allows us and then multiplication is
really going to correspond to the binary
and operation and we can always
represent binary not by the 1 minus X
function and therefore if we get
addition multiplication over any over
any ring this is going to give us this
is going to give us what we want so this
is this is going to be our goal when we
want to construct and working encryption
and just to say that while fully
homomorphic is the fully homomorphic
encryption is our ultimate goal we're
actually going to be pretty happy with
what's called the level of the fully
homomorphic encryption scheme so in a
level fully homomorphic encryption
scheme we actually don't sort of commit
to being able to evaluate all functions
or rather only founded depth functions
and what we want is actually
to be able to produce escape for any
depth Balan that we can get so we sort
of know in advance what's the most
complicated or the deepest circuit that
we will want that we want to evaluate
and then we can produce a scheme that
supports this functionality so this is
what fully homomorphic encryption is all
about this is what we were going to talk
about in this talk and of course I
cannot mention a fully homomorphic
encryption without sort of mentioning
it's sort of this is this great story
reversed every month and their two
sauces came up with the idea of fully
homomorphic encryption back in 1978 so
this is really just the dawn of public
key encryption we didn't even have I
guess the magic security at the time I
still soon but this wouldn't it be great
idea came up but it was really far from
from being achievable and that remained
the case for for many years despite many
attempts until this great breakthrough
by by Craig Gentry which wasn't very
soon at the time and I guess late 2008
and he showed the first candidate the
first scheme that actually sort of
supported this this functionality and
security and it sort of made the whole
field really sort of bubble in steam and
there were a lot of developments and a
lot of great ideas but in this talk I'm
actually only going to present I guess
the most modern approach to fully
homomorphic encryption and this is this
approximate eigenvector method presented
by Gentry Sahai in waters and this is
only from two years ago as Chris
mentioned and the basic idea is the
following so we want to get we want to
get this home morphic evaluation to work
for say addition and multiplication and
we notice that if we have two matrices
c1 and c2 that have the same eigen
vector s and in c1 this eigenvector
corresponds to AG in value M 1 and C 2
it corresponds to I can value M 2 then
if we add these two matrices then this
new the the sum of the two matrices is
well it's going to have the same eigen
vector s
and the corresponding eigenvalue is
going to be the sum of these two values
m1 and m2 and if we multiply these two
matrices and actually even if we
multiply them in the in the opposite
order this is a non commutative
operation then the add the eigen value
the correspondence s is going to be m1
times m2 and we're actually going to
sort of see it in a little more detail
but this sort of basic idea sort of
gives rise to the following
I guess meta meta scheme so why don't we
have our cipher text be matrices and the
message that is encoded that is
encrypted in the matrix is going to be
an eigenvalue that the corresponds to an
eigenvector which is secret so you know
at least hopefully if this eigenvector
is secret then perhaps the message is
hidden but if I know what this what this
vector is is then I can recover the
message so if we had an encryption
scheme with this with this high-level
structure then we would be able to do
these these homomorphic operations so
just to pick some some field to work
with let's say that we work a modulo Q
for some integer q and so we will get
home morphic for addition multiplication
and this will give us full hole morphism
and this seems to be again so this this
is a great high-level outline but it's
it's really easy to see that it's
insecure because it's it's pretty easy
to compute eigenvalues Keim's so at
least if you want to sort of get the
sort of at most level of security that
we want semantic security this seems to
not be the best the best idea so it's
tempting to just sort of toss it and and
try to try something else but actually
you can think about just maybe slightly
tweaking this idea so what if my secret
key is now really an eigenvector
but it's approximately an eigenvector
and by that I mean the following so
first of all let me sort of warn you
that I'm going to you
instead of the secret key being an
eigenvector of the ciphertext it's going
to be an eigenvector of the transposed
and this just means that I'm multiplying
on the left instead of on the right I
hope this notation is not too confusing
it will be helpful for the rest of the
morning so instead of so what we say
when we say approximate eigenvector is
that when I take the secret key vector
and multiply it by the ciphertext I'm
going to get message time secret plus
some small noise or in other words going
to be approximately equal to the message
times secret so if there was an equality
here then this means that really s is an
eigenvector with eigenvalue m but we're
sort of relaxing this this condition and
this is sort of the approximate the
approximate eigenvector idea and for now
take it on faith that if we when we are
able to achieve this this schema then
such ciphertext are going to be
decrypted well so long as this noise
vector has a very low norm and the snore
needs to be much smaller than QQ is the
modulus that we work over so we would
like to would like to see if you know
just relaxing this perfect condition to
a relaxed one it's still going to give
us the whole morph isn't that we want so
let's see how this works so let's say
that we have two of these ciphertext C 1
and C 2
such that C 1 equals to M 1 s plus C 1
and C 2 well just the equivalent and
let's say that we start with noises that
really are really small much smaller
than Q and our goal remember we have
this this server that has an encryption
of the input so encryption of all these
bits of the input and it wants to
execute a circuit so in particular we
want to get to cypher we want to go from
to ciphertext C 1 and C 2 to an
encryption of their sum to be able to go
to encryption of their sum and to an
encryption of their product so in order
to get the sum well let's just try to
add these two matrices it seemed to work
before when we didn't have noise so
let's see what happens so
I let's say that I generated C and a c1
plus c2 let's see what happens when I
try to decrypt c1 plus c2 with the same
secret key that worked for c1 and c2 so
this just gives me s times c1 plus s
times c2 okay okay and I'm just going to
open these two expressions based on
these sort of what we know on on c1 and
c2 and of course we only do it in our
head that the the whole morphic
evaluated the server itself does not
know does not know s but we should check
that really this homework evaluation
means something and what we get is
really m1 plus m2 times s plus e1 plus
e2 so we really get something of the
same foreign form as what we start with
which is great which means that we
really really get this home morphic home
or fee correctness for addition but our
new noise is the sum of the old noises
so the noise grows a little this is
perhaps a little a little worrisome but
if we start with noises that are really
really small then at least for a few for
few operations we're going to be ok so
at least is going to give us some some
level of who morphism ok so that's good
now let's see what happens when we try
to multiply so again before we said well
maybe for multiplication we're going to
take c1 times c2
let's see what this gives us when we try
to decrypt so s times c1 times c2 I'm
going to try to see what what happens so
x times c1 is just m1 times s plus c1
this comes from here and this this
multiplies C to open the parentheses you
get M 1 C 2 s so remember that the MSR
scalar so I'm pretty freely I'm moving
them from side to side of these vectors
and matrices and so forth so the MS are
scalars but everything else is non
commutative that's what we're all right
that's right and again this should be s
times C 2 thanks Christian tank so s
times C 2 just
here is going to be M 2 times S Plus e 2
and we have this additional this
additional term which is e 1 times e 2
which we just sort of keep carrying
around because well we don't know how to
break it any further and what we get in
the end is m1 so m1 times m2 times s
plus m1 times e2 plus e1 times c2 so we
got something that kind of looks like
what we had before so we have m1 times
m2 times s which is sort of our new
message x times s but for the noise well
we get something more complicated than
before we get m1 times e2 plus e1 times
c2 it's sort of a symmetric in a sense
it gets something else if you did it the
other way around and it's a good
question whether this thing is going to
remain small or not it really depends on
the specific implementation of this of
the scheme so it seems like our noise is
going to grow and in order to control
the growth in order to make to make this
thing manageable we really want C to to
be small and there's sort of many
notions of how you can define it in the
tightest way but for us we're just going
to think that we want all of the entries
of c2 to be really small and if that if
that was the case then really we could
argue that c2 does not make this part of
the noise too large so it seems like it
could work if we had an if we had an
approximate eigenvalue eigenvector
encryption scheme then we should be able
to get at least some sort of morphism
and now let's see how to actually
construct a scheme like that and we're
going to use oh and the I should say
that you can also do the the opposite
operation I guess I did so we're going
to use the learning with errors
assumption which had been very very
useful in cryptography since reg have
introduced it in 2005 and actually also
a little before without knowing and this
assumption says the following I guess
the the intuitive statement is to say
that if you have random noisy linear
equations
jululu an integer then they're going to
be computationally indistinguishable
from uniform and to be a little more
concrete what we have is the setting is
the following so we think about a
uniform matrix a and a is I guess wide
and in short it's n by M so and as this
dimension in M is and capital M is this
dimension so this is just going to be a
uniform matrix and what we're thinking
about we're thinking about this this
matrix as a sequence of coefficients for
linear equations what does that mean we
have a secret N dimensional vector s and
we take the product of the vector s and
the matrix a so this actually gives us
sort of a sequence of linear equations
where the coefficients of the equations
are the columns of a and the variables
are the the components of the vector s
so we take these these these linear
equations and actually we add some noise
to them and thus noise is just going to
be a vector of small entries in order to
get the tightest reduction you may have
heard that you want to take this vector
to be drawn from a Gaussian distribution
or a discrete Gaussian distribution but
for the purpose of this talk we're not
going to care about it we're just going
to think about this as a vector of very
short elements in particular each
element in this vector is going to be
smaller in absolute value then some
alpha times Q and alpha is going to be
really really tiny and we're going to
see how tiny it needs to be later on so
we take these linear these random linear
equations we add noise to them and we
get we get some vector B what does it
mean to be indistinguishable from
uniform well so we have this B which
equals to s times a plus noise and now
let's think about the joy distribution
of this uniform matrix a and the vector
B it's not hard to see that this
distribution is going to be
statistically far from uniform at least
if this if this alpha is small enough
and the pasina's just think about so s
times a
is going to be a random element in the
row span of a and this row span of a a
is going to be is since it's wide and
short this is just a hyperplane in Z Q
to the M so we have this fairly low
dimensional hyper plane and we take a
random point in this hyper plane
obviously if I give you these two things
it's not it's going to be statistically
far from uniform and computationally
distinguishable from uniform but turns
out that if you just add some noise so
if you think about this like as a fuzzy
hyper plane in in this in this high
dimensional space well it's still going
to be statistically far from uniform but
the learning with errors assumption is
that this is actually going to be
computationally hard to distinguish from
just the uniform distribution so from
the case where we sampled both a and B
just uniformly and independently so this
is this is pretty great and we even
think that it's true in particular we
actually have like strong reasons to
believe that it's true it had been shown
in the sequence of work starting with
this work of rigor that if you can
distinguish this from from uniform then
well really the very I'm saying I'm
saying the statement very roughly then
this is at least as hard as
approximating short vector problems in
the n dimensional lattices and this is
true in the worst case so this is an
average case problem it talks about
distributions everything here is drawn
from from some distributions and yet if
you're able to solve this this average
case problem so if you're able to
distinguish these two distributions you
are actually able to approximate
approximate short vectors in really any
lattice that I give you any n
dimensional lattice that I give you and
the approximation factor as you would
expect serve deteriorates as alpha goes
down so obviously if alpha was like I
guess 1 over infinity or 0 then then
this would easily be distinguishable
this problem becomes hard and as alpha
times Q becomes becomes bigger this
problem becomes becomes harder but from
this point on we're now going to be
concerned about
whether this is whether this is hard or
not being will feel pretty confident to
use this as our as our hardest
assumption and I actually want to sort
of rearrange the notation will be more
convenient for me to just think about
the matrix that that consists of - a and
B and I hope this is not going to be too
confusing but from now on I'm just going
to call this a so my new a is just going
to be what used to be - a and B this is
sort of the traditional notation but
this new one is going to be more more
convenient for me and what we have for
this for this new matrix is that if I
multiply it by s concatenated with one
then really what we get here is B minus
s times a and B minus s times a is going
to be this short vector so what we so
what we actually have so this new form
of lwe says that we have a matrix a we
can generate a matrix a and the vector s
such that s times a equals to this very
short vector so obviously a is is very
far from being very far from being
uniform but on the other hand if I just
show you a itself without telling you
that I have the secret key this is going
to be computationally indistinguishable
from uniform so from now on we're just
going to think about having being able
to generate matrices like this and I
showed you this follows from their
learning with Aris assumption all right
so how do we how do we get an encryption
scheme from from such from from this
from this LWB structure so well this is
I guess based on ribs ribs first first
paper and also on this paper by
Applebaum cash pocket and Sahai
that gave an extension that will be very
useful for us so as you would guess the
public key is just going to be my matrix
a and my secret key is just going to be
the secret vector s how do I encrypt I
take my matrix and I multiply it by a
uniform binary vector so this is just
not going to be zero one vector even
though we think about it modulo Q it's
still only going to contain zeros and
ones and it's going to be it's going to
be M dimensional so I multiply on the
right here and I add some other value Y
and this value is actually going to be
the encoding of the message so here is
where the sort of message them
encrypting going to come into the play
not going to tell you how exactly at
this point so I'm taking this AR plus y
and I'm getting my I get my ciphertext
so my ciphertext is this is this C sub y
and to see why this is a secure
encryption scheme well in the eyes of an
attacker who doesn't see the secret key
only the public key this matrix a is
just a uniform it's just a uniform
matrix it's computationally
indistinguishable from uniform and had
it really been a uniform matrix we get
from the from the leftover hash lemma
that a times are even given a is going
to be statistically close to uniform and
independent of of a and therefore we can
conclude that the the Joint Distribution
of the ciphertext and the secret the
public key and ciphertext regardless of
what this vector Y is is going to be
computationally indistinguishable from
from being jointly uniform so long as M
is large enough and this is the and this
is going to be this is going to give us
security for for this key alright good
so we have a secure scheme but that sort
of we kind of want to be able to decrypt
so what happens when we try to decrypt
the ciphertext
so hopefully this sort of Lego
presentation sort of hints that the way
to decrypt will be to just take the
secret key and multiply it with with the
ciphertext if nothing else just because
the dimensions match so what happens
what happens when we do it
we take the secret key times the
ciphertext well what is this ciphertext
it's a times R plus y so I'm taking the
secret key and multiplying it by a times
R so we know
s times a is this small noise vector so
when we multiplied by R we're going to
get really the inner product of the
vector ADA and the vector R both of
these are small R small vectors if I
remember we said that it's the absolute
values are at most alpha times Q and R
we just chose it to be 0 1 so it really
it really has short entries so we're
going to get something that is pretty
small it's going to be a noise value but
the second part perhaps more interesting
is we again we take s times the the
ciphertext so this part we took care of
but now we have the vector Y and what we
get is the inner product of our secret
key and this encoding of the myth of the
message Y and what you get is sort of an
approximate way to encrypt this inner
product of secret key times y for any Y
that I want and I can do that without
without knowing s itself so I can
actually encrypt some function of the
secret key without knowing without
knowing what what the secret key is and
okay so to see perhaps seems weird and
for one thing you'd want to perhaps see
how you can just encrypt messages to
your own one so let me show you like a
very rudimentary way to do it so let's
just think that when I want to encrypt a
zero I'm just going to take this vector
Y to be zero and what I want to encrypt
the one I'm going to take this to be a
completely random vector in that case
when I try to decrypt if y equals to
zero that I'm really only going to get
this small noise but if Y is uniform
then with very high probability I'm not
going to get something that is small of
course there are much better ways to to
encrypt the scheme but I don't want to
get into that we'll see a cool way to
encrypt with with additional properties
but this is sort of the basic encryption
scheme that that we're going to use and
actually we're going to generalize it a
bit because if we can encrypt with
respect to vectors why not do it for
matrices so what we're going to do is
actually take this these Y's instead of
being just vectors
we're going to sort of expand them to
matrices so to encrypt our encryption is
just going to look like a bunch of the
previous encryptions so we're going to
get a ciphertext which is a matrix but
each of the columns of the matrix is
just like a column ciphertext like we
saw in the previous slide so instead of
multiplying by one row vector that is
zero one we're going to multiply by
capital and such such vectors so we're
going to get a times R plus some matrix
Y and now our message is really needs to
be in our message needs to be encoded in
in this small n plus one times capital n
size matrix so if you were wasteful
before just sort of encrypting one bit
in a vector now we're going to be even
more wasteful and just encrypt in order
to improve one bit we're actually going
to have this entire ciphertext of
ciphertext and this matrix of a
ciphertext but so this this I claim is
going to be a step in the right
direction because in the end we want to
implement this approximate eigenvector
method and for that we do need our
cipher text to be 2b matrices all right
so the encryption is going to work in
exactly the same way we're just going to
get instead of just getting one entry
we're going to get a vector of entries
each of which is a decryption of the
respective column so I'm going to take s
times CY and what I'm going to get is
this noise vector a dot times R and
again this ADA is is short and this R is
a matrix of zero one entries and
therefore this is just going to be a
vector of small entries this is our
noise vector plus vector s times times
the matrix Y which which encodes the
message all right good
how do you use this this to get the
approximate approximate eigenvector well
we need two things so first of all we
need to choose Y as a function of our
message m in a way that will allow us to
do all these eigen eigen vector tricks
so I claim that this is going to be the
easier task or I guess this is going to
be the test that we're going to see
second but first I want to
handle this trying to get the entries to
be small so remember that we needed our
our scheme to have small entries in
order for the for this noise when we do
multiplication to not grow by too much
so well in in this in this particular
scheme that that we're thinking about
this ciphertext matrix actually looks
like a uniform matrix in zq so obviously
it's not going to have it's not going to
have small entries so we need to come up
with a way to take matrices that have
large entries and make them into
matrices that have small entries and the
way i usually describe it is the second
stupidest thing that you can think of
so the first stupidest thing is is that
well if I want to have take a big number
and making it to a small number well the
first stupidest thing would be to just
scale it down but this doesn't work in
this case because in a sense scaling
down is equivalent to doing nothing but
perhaps the second stupidest thing would
be to just take this number and break it
into I guess by now it's binary it's
binary digits each binary digits is
small so everything is small so this is
exactly what we're going to do we're
going to take this matrix this this
ciphertext matrix that we started with
and break each of its entries into its
its binary representation so let's take
an example think about the matrix 3 5 1
4 mod 8 and the binary the binary
decomposition of this matrix well 3 is
just 0 1 1 1 is 0 0 1 5 is 1 0 1 and 4
is 1 0 0 done I've got a matrix well
it's kind of bigger than the or taller
than the original matrix but maybe
that's ok and it only has small entries
so this is this is what we wanted but on
the other hand this is the second
stupidest thing that you can you can
come up with you lose all the structure
that you had here I mean all these all
the other linear algebraic structure
that you had it seems to have been gone
what does this mean to take you know the
secret vector s times this bit matrix
that's kind of weird so
the cool thing about this is that even
though this operation is in particular
nonlinear the inverse of the inverse of
this I claim is going to be a linear
operation and is going to be extremely
useful so I claim that giving this bit
decomposition of C I can actually
multiply it by some some red matrix and
get and get C back and just maybe take a
minute to think about how how you do it
how do you sort of take the binary
representation and convert it back into
the number this is really a linear
operation so this matrix is just going
to look like you know the powers of 2 4
2 1 4 2 1 on the diagonal and 0
everywhere else so this is often
referred to as the gadget matrix and
sometimes you change the orders of the
the orders of the columns and this this
still works it just corresponds to
different binary representation so when
you when you take this binary
decomposition and multiply it by the
gadget matrix you really get your
original matrix back so this may not be
as stupid as we thought because the
structure the linear structure doesn't
really go away and just to sort of
emphasize that this this operation is
really serve the inverse of a linear
operation this is usually denoted by G
inverse of C so G is the matrix but G
inverses is a function so G G inverse is
like an operator net non linear operator
that works on matrices but it's left
inverse is just just a matrix and this
notation is going to be extremely
convenient as we will see in the in the
next talks so what we have here is that
well if we if we thought about trying to
decrypt a cipher text a normal cipher
text so taking s times C then this is
exactly equivalent to taking s times G
so as test times the gadget matrix times
G inverse of C so in a sense we have a
linear way to sort of treat these binary
decompositions of off ciphertext good so
this so this problem is is solved
we are able to represent matrices in in
a short way and just sort of point your
attention I can generate this gadget
matrix for any for any number of rows
that I want and the property that it's
going to have is that if it has K rows
then it's going to have K times log Q
columns so the proportions are sort of
kept so now let's let's actually see
this the final encryption scheme so
remember our public key is this matrix a
which is wide and short our secret key
is a vector and we have this property
that s times a is as short is a short
vector it up now to encrypt to encrypt a
message
M would randomness R so this R is just
going to be this big 0 1 matrix that we
saw before what we do is take a times R
plus M times G so my Y matrix the matrix
that I that I was alluding to before is
really just taking them the my message m
and multiplying it with the gadget the
gadget matrix G and this is going to be
so the dimensions are going to be really
the same as the dimensions of the gadget
matrix it's going to be n plus 1 by
capital n which is n plus 1 log all
right so why why does this work why is
this why is M times G the right choice
for for the for the matrix Y for the
encryption well what we have for this
types for this type of encryption is
that when I take when I sort of take my
ciphertext and multiply it by the secret
key which is going to be an essential
part of our decryption process what we
get is a small vector e like we saw
before this is what you always get and
then you get s times the matrix Y which
in this this case is the same as the
message m which I can move to the side
times s times G and perhaps at first
glance it's not clear what's the
eigenvector here and it's not clear
what's that where's the short matrix but
I can actually sort of presented in a
slightly different
a so s times C is really just s times G
times G inverse of C which is we just
saw that and we get that s G times G
inverse of C is small noise plus M times
s G so if you want to sort of go back to
this the eigenvector intuition then you
can think that s you can think about s
times G as being an approximate
eigenvector for this G inverse of C
matrix which is both going to be square
now because well the proportion
magically just just matched when you
take Jane but it's not magic
that's it has to work the the G inverse
just sort of makes this makes this
ciphertext matrix square so it's going
to be square and it's going to have an
approximate eigenvector which is s times
G but actually this intuition that was
pretty useful in getting us to this
point
were really we can abandon it from this
point and on and although I'm going to
care about is that I'm getting this
encryption scheme for which this
invariant holds so my cipher texts are
these matrices such that s times C
equals M times s G Plus small noise and
now let's see how to do well first of
all decryption so I didn't I didn't show
you how to decrypt these how to decrypt
the ciphertext it doesn't matter that
much but let's let's see it anyway so in
order to decrypt the ciphertext C I'm
going to compute s times C it's going to
give me this thing
but in order to extract M I'm going to
do this this little trick I'm going to
multiply by G inverse of this vector
what is this vector well u n plus 1 is
just the unit vector at 0 0 0 0 and 1 in
the end and I'm going to and I'm just
multiplying it by the scalar q over 2 so
a nice property why this why do why did
I choose this vector so perhaps you
remember ages ago when we sort of
defined as this vector s we had a
slightly shorter s and we added one in
the end this means that the inner
product of this you with our vector s is
going to be 1 so this is a vector that
is served there
right inverse of our secret key so what
happens when we do this multiplication
well we get e times that the noise e
times this J inverse of something we
know that this is kind of small so we
take a small noise it's multiplied by J
inverse that's fine and this is going to
be plus M times M times s G times this
gene universe we know that g and g
universe go away
so at this point this this becomes sort
of this is where the fun happens
whenever we see J and G inverse we can
just sort of remove them we move both of
them and what we get is something small
plus Q over 2 times m times in a product
of s and U which is just 1 so we can
just remove it so what you get is well
if M equals 0 then you get something
really small and if M equals 1 then you
get Q over 2 which is really sort of the
largest element mod Q plus something
small so it's very easy to distinguish
these two apart and this is this is how
the scheme is decrypted and now let's
see how to do how to do home morphic
operations so again the sort of the
invariant that we want to keep
throughout the whole morphic evaluation
is that we want to have ciphertext such
that s times c equals a plus msg so so
so long as this holds we can decrypt
that's that's what we saw so long as
this holds and the noise is is small
enough so in order to do homework
multiplication what we're going to do is
we're going to take we have C 1 and C 2
and we take C 1 now we don't multiply it
by C 2 adjust the dimensions don't work
so we take C 1 which kind of looks like
this and multiply it by G inverse of C 2
which luckily both has the right
dimension so it's a square matrix and it
has short entries which is going to be
very useful and let's see that that we
get this is invariant that we started
with so we have s times C c1 times G
inverse C 2 s times C 1 is just e 1 plus
M 1 s G it gets multiplied by G inverse
of C 2
we get e 1 times C 2 so 3 universityt -
sorry so e 1 is uh it's going to be
fairly small hopefully and G universe is
just going to be a zero one matrix so we
remain in the pretty small domain times
m1 s G times G inverse of C - so now the
way the way that the scheme the scheme
had been constructed sort of Garrett
sort of gives us that this s time G with
s times G which just seemed destructive
now just cancels out with this G inverse
and what we get is e 1 G inverse e 2
plus M 1 SC 2 so G G inverse goes away
SS times C 2 we know how to we know how
to expand it further we just have M 1
times e 2 plus n 2 s G that's again
coming from up here
and so just opening the parentheses and
putting everything together well we see
that we have M 1 from here M 2 from here
s G so we have M 1 M 2 s G so this is
good this is the output of the
multiplication operation now what do we
have is the noise well we have m1 times
e2 that comes from here so this is going
to be e2 is kind of small and then 1 is
0 1 so this remains pretty small but
that was the part that we sort of were
were pretty relaxed about also from
before the what used to be the bad part
we used to have V 1 times C 2 here in
the serve naive naive approach but now
we have a 1 times the inverse of C 2 and
this G inverse really has just small
entries and indeed this this new noise
is going to be is going to be pretty
small we can bound it relative to do
with noises that we started with so this
is how you do this is how you do a
multiplication so if you didn't sort of
follow all the specific derivation the
multiplication is defined like this and
when you sort of open everything to
everything up you really get the same
invariant that we started with except
the noise is going to be this e 1 G
University 2 plus M 1 M 1 e 2 and I'm
almost done so I just wanted to before
thing I want to point out is that I did
multiplication but actually doing NAND
is just as easy we just take the this
gadget matrix matrix G minus the
multiplication so it's it's not hard to
verify that taking G minus ciphertext is
equivalent to making the message into 1
minus M so 1 minus multiplication gives
us gives us NAND and this whole thing
works exactly the same way in fact the
noise really is the noise expression is
the same in both cases and this G
inverse is just going to affect what
what happens here so what we get is that
when we do multiplication when we do an
end the basic operation for for our
circuit our noise is going to grow as
follows so I'm giving a very loose
analysis here you can be you could be
much much tighter and get somewhat
better get someone some is somewhat
better expression but and I see they
also swapped a 1 and a 2 here I'm sorry
so we have a 1 that gets multiplied by
this by this G inverse let's just say
that this this grows the norm by a
factor of and the dimension of the
matrix on average is going to be much
better and we have this should be e 2
times times M 1 and M 1 is just 0 1 so
in the end if we started with some II 1
e 2 with norm normally 1 in or me to
what you get in the end is at most an
increase of an N plus 1 factor in the in
the amplitude of the noise and you know
it is a good or bad well depends on your
perspective it's not as good as what we
had for addition which was just constant
constant increase but now on the other
hand it's much better than what you'd
get trivially in fact it's good enough
to get to get home morphic to get
non-trivial homomorphic capabilities and
i just want to point out that this this
noise expression it's uh perhaps very
strange but one property that that we'll
see that is going to become very useful
is
at these this this is actually a linear
operation on the original noises on e 1
and E 2 and linear in the sense that if
I know the cipher text or the ciphertext
C 2 and the message m 1 then I sort of
know how the how my old noise is going
to progress into into the new noise and
well if you know the message then
there's not this doesn't make much sense
in terms of homework encryption but
we'll see that in other cases it is
going to sort of make sense to know both
the cipher text and the message
but actually not the noise so this is
sort of just a preview but just to wrap
up we showed how to do one gate if we
want to evaluate an entire circuit then
with each level of the whole morphic
evaluation our noise grows by a factor
of this n plus 1 se and when we evaluate
the depth D circuit we get a noise
growth of something like n to the power
D and n is like a polynomial in our
security parameter or size of size of
the keys of our scheme and so forth and
so in order to make this decrypt able we
need the amplitude of the noise to be
much much smaller than much much smaller
than Q or at least somewhat smaller than
Q so we need this alpha to be really
small to be something smaller than 1
over N to the D so it grows
exponentially with the depth of the
circuit that we want to evaluate and
again whether this is good or bad as a
matter of perspective
it's the almost the best that we can get
and it's good enough to get to get
practically any notion of morph isn't
that we want so just to wrap up I'm a
little behind I see we showed an
encryption scheme the way you encrypt is
you take the public key matrix a
multiplied by 0 1 matrix R plus mg this
invariant is that when you take when you
take your secret key times C you get
noise plus message x SG to do homework
homework evaluation I just take two
ciphertext C 1 and C 2 do the binary
decomposition and and multiply if I want
an and I take
- this whole thing and this just gives
us home morphism we only only saw how to
do bounded depth because at some point
your nose is going to grow too much and
you're not going to be able to decrypt
this is solvable but not in this talk so
one way to do it is to sort of choose
the parameters appropriately so if i
nodi ahead of time then i can choose the
parameters for this lwe instance so that
the scheme is secure under some
exponential approximation to lattice
problems so fairly strong assumption
gently presented like a great idea
called bootstrapping so the
bootstrapping procedure actually allows
you to get to get a scheme for every for
any depth without compromising on the on
the parameters of the L of the lwe
instance so these parameters are not
going to grow but something else will
grow the size of the of the public key
but in a way that does not affect the
hardness and actually using this
approach you can actually get home
morphic encryption based on much weaker
assumption namely the hardness of
approximate you'll have this problems to
within a polynomial a polynomial factor
in the dimension and actually but still
there's this annoying order of
quantifiers that I need to know the
depth and only then I can give you a
scheme and again this is shown by Gentry
that if you combine this bootstrapping
with an additional assumption which we
don't know if it's sure or not that's
the circle or security of this of this
encryption scheme so this is an
additional security requirement of the
scheme then you can really get just one
scheme that works for any for any depth
circuit and this will really give you
the full-fledged fully homomorphic
encryption so really I'm already behind
let's get Danielle to tell us about
switchers